You may have heard about the impact of climate change on our planet, specifically on the Arctic
Which is heated twice as fast. But what will happen?
If all the ice melted on the ground?
Bill: I can help out here! When we drink water you and me
We drink non-salty water, we drink fresh water.
Of all the water in the world, most of it is brackish water, only 3% of it is non-salty.
You can not get all those 3% in 70% of those 3%
Frozen! Thirty million cubic kilometers of frozen water!
It is a large amount of frozen water, so big that if you put a layer of it
With a width of a thousand meters, will cover North America.
This is a very large amount of frozen water, group!
On the ground, frozen water forms glaciers, ice sheets, frosty soil and snow
But a great part of the Arctic is an ocean, so there, the frozen water takes shape
Floating sea ice, such as icebergs. Because it is in direct contact with the water that becomes warm
Sea ice will be the first thing to dissolve as the planet warms up
In fact, this year, NASA has published reports that the amount of Arctic ice has reached its lowest level
In January, February, April, May and June 2016.
Bill: Then the world becomes warmer and warmer and the ice melts
Very soon you will be able to sail your ship from Europe to Russia,
Cross the frozen pole directly, with no ice on your way.
This may be good for some shipping companies, but for marine life species such as polar bears
The seals! They do not have their own natural habitat, all their citizens disappear, melt underneath.
Animals living in the ocean, such as the hippocampus and the sea, are not immune to this change either.
With the melting of sea ice, energy companies take the opportunity to look for
Unutilized sources through a method known as seismic explosion,
Where they release air explosives into the water to set the ocean floor
And find oil. Of course, this method causes damage to the entire Northern Ocean ecosystem.
Causing physical trauma and re-settlement of whales.
For sea levels, the melting of sea ice will not have a noticeable effect.
This is because the floating ice actually displaces an equal amount of water
Which will produce when dissolved, so this effect can be ignored.
Moreover, more than 95% of the Earth's ice is on land
It is often found in the vast glacier covering Greenland and Antarctica
Where there are complete mountain chains, almost the size of the Alps, buried completely under the ice
So, what if all the ice melted on land?
Bill: If all this ice melts, the oceans will have more water
If the sea level, as measured from the coasts, will rise.
Will rise by 70 meters. This is a large quantity, group. Half the population of the Earth
They live on the coasts of the seas, where you get all the business activities!
They will have to move to another place, where will they go?
And who will pay for them?
Tokyo, New York, Sao Paulo, Mumbai, Shanghai and Jakarta, all on the coast
They also get the largest cities in the world.
Even rising sea levels by a few feet could cause $ 1 trillion of damage due to flooding
in the year. An increase of 10 meters may cause migration of more than 630 million people
About 10% of the population.
At 25 meters, 1.4 billion people, almost 20% of humanity, will be homeless.
To illustrate the impact of 70 meters, the sea continues to rise and will sink a majority
Sea borders in the eastern United States, the majority of the West Coast
The entire state of Florida, vast areas of Asia including Bangladesh.
A large area of ​​northern China, and will create a new inland sea in Australia.
In the North and South Pole of the planet, we have a lot of ice. Ice white.
Ice reflects the sunlight of space.
But there is a feedback mechanism, everything leads to the other. With increasing earth temperature
The ice melts. With melting ice, reflects less amount of sunlight into space
Making the world continue to be warmer. The sunlight is absorbed
By dark liquid oceans. If, with thawing
The world becomes warmer. The sea becomes livid.
The world's oceans cut off currents that serve as giant conveyor belts.
These currents are partially operated by the difference in salinity
Between the parts of the ocean.
If, if melting of the ice layer of Greenland cause the discharge of a large amount of fresh, unsalted water to the North Atlantic
It can cause turbulence in currents.
Bill: If the conveyor belt takes chemicals, takes nutrients around the world,
Which in turn feed plankton.
Which in turn feed the fish.
Which we feed.
Half the oxygen you breathe is made by ocean plants.
So, no one wants to mess with it.
Moreover, with the increasing warmth of the sea surface
From Greenland, Gulf currents are likely to change slightly.
If these currents change, which keeps Europe warm now,
Europe may not keep that warmer anymore. So crops will need to grow elsewhere.
Who will plant them, who will pay them, and who will feed the other
And what happens? This is serious! When we melt the ice.
We've actually gone to the North Pole to see things put out now by ourselves
While we recorded it all and we were really shocked by what we found.
Click here to see our documentary, "End of the Arctic"
Where we learn about the Eskimo communities that are fighting to defend their human rights
Against oil companies and the Canadian government
All this while trying to save the Arctic from the harsh impact of climate change
And seismic explosion.
You can help us raise awareness by sharing this video and signing our petition
To press the government to prevent seismic explosion in the Arctic
Which causes long-term impact on wildlife
And the people of the Iskimo who live in northern Canada.
Check the links in the Description box.
Join our movement to protect the frozen pole and our planet.
Subscribe to more weekly science videos. Translation: team translate @autrjim